What is one thing that you do that absolutely pisses feminist off?
I'll go first.
I take my physical fitness and my appearance very seriously,
not only for myself, but also for my husband.
I am his and I want him to be proud of me when he sees me in public
or just when we're alone.
Our life and our modern day culture is full of temptation.
Sorry, there's a freaking fly on me.
And my man is a good man, but he's still a man.
So if he's gonna be being a dirty old little man,
I want him to be dirty with me.
And I don't think there's anything wrong with saying that.
But if I tell women that I lost
like 50 pounds in two months after my last baby,
and I did it in an epic biohacking,
safe way that even doubled my milk supply,
I mean, it just gets their goat
to know that I care about my physical appearance.
For my man, yes,
of course. A lot of it was for me.
My self confidence, my health.
I don't wanna be someone that he has to take care of when we get old,
just like he should wanna take care of himself for me.
Second thing, people are like,
that's so creepy. He doesn't like me to cut my hair.
And I've always been a super,
like, traditional,
so that doesn't bother me at all.
But like, I worked so hard this year,
To get my hair like this. Oh, wait,
there it is.
Oh, yeah.
He likes long hair on me, and that's okay,
but, man,
it pisses women off when I say that.
Like, I don't cut my hair,
and I grow it out for him.
Also do all this biohacking stuff and anti aging.
I wear patches every single night for wrinkles.
I wear a stem cell patch that, like,
is clinically proven to reverse your age.
And to be clear, it's not that I have a fear of aging,
but statistically, like,
we age way quicker than we're supposed to,
or that we even did decades ago.
And that's because we live in a toxic environment full of crap,
and we're wearing a toxic suit every single day,
toxic makeup, toxic everything.
So it's also for my health,
trying to combat chronic illness, autoimmune.
I have an entire Instagram page on that,
because that's, like,
a totally different initiative,
what I do here. But, yeah,
I take my beauty and my appearance and my health very seriously.
Not just for me, but for him.
I mean, he's my partner.
You don't wanna be hitched up to someone
that's gonna drag you down for the rest of your life.
He's already seven years older than me,
and you already know that.
I love age gaps between men and women,
specifically men being older.
But, yeah,
it makes me feel pretty freaking good when he's proud and he's like,
damn, that's My wife.
So I go to the gym, I take care of my body,
take care of my wrinkles, I take care of my face,
I grow my hair out for him.
There's so much temptation in this world,
and if he's gonna be looking at other things like most men do,
I just want him to be like, nah,
my biatch is hotter.
But watch how many angry comments I'm gonna get to this,
because it lights a fire under women's butts
when I say I like to look good for my man
because I think it's important.